So, when talking about imitation, we see the nature side. In that, all the
children began to speak at about the same time. And they were able to use
language as functional tool. And we also see the nurture side. And this was the
number of words that children were exposed to based on their family type. And
also whether they heard more encouraging words or discouraging words. So, the
important point to take home here is that we should try to expose our little
ones to as many words as possible, to increase their vocabulary. You may ask
why is vocabulary important? Well, Hart and Risley found an interesting study.
They found a strong positive correlation between children's vocabulary size at
age three and their language test scores at age nine and ten. Now remember that
this is a correlational study, so we can't see there was a cause and effect
relationship. But it is a nice demonstration of how powerful different
environments are in terms of language development.